foreign
[Applause]
fighting game rivalries are the heart
and soul of Competitive Gaming igniting
intense passions and driving players to
push their limits
[Applause]
these rivalries often emerge organically
as top players consistently Clash on the
virtual Battlefield
in Tekken these battles transcend pixels
and become legendary these Fierce
competitors each with their own unique
playstyle and character preferences fuel
the community's excitement making every
match a spectacle
the history in Tekken tournaments is
woven with the threads of these
rivalries creating a narrative that
continues to evolve with every heated
Exchange in every match
here are the best rivalries in Tekken
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you're both going to be using Ling gonna
be the mirror match Revenge match from
that first attending Japan that took
place who do you guys think's gonna win
this feature yeah oh yes these guys are
trying their best to open each other
right now oh
Anaconda
oh God that was someone someone oh my
God that was so sick did you see that
I've never seen that before yeah the
option select versus aop from one
running three did you press the button
no she did it here we go
to my birthday
no
[Music]
and we're here for the 10v10 USA versus
EU exhibition are you guys ready
he don't want to win he don't want to
win we don't want to win Landon wants to
win oh I said Landon wants to win
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah oh why did that hit oh my
God
take him off
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
you said we were quiet
USA Make some noise
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God oh
USA
[Applause]
Make some noise
at nine U S A to take it no big of a
ritual I see
very well paid to both teams there 10A
is the final score 2na
games that in the end so many final
final rounds and there it is
[Music]
foreign
my email broke
energy
to do there's no time left
oh good bunch
[Applause]
oh my gosh
gonna do
oh
[Applause]
be very careful here oh
right side of the neck
[Applause]
[Music]
and he was able to utilize in such a way
that it comes up right you have to be
here
get up
wow the full combo he used everything
perfectly this time it still oh I've
never seen that before and jdcr keeps
Tech rolling and this is what you get
against the player as good as me you
keep testing him you know uh he's gonna
definitely answer those
foreign
[Music]
I got a taser on him
oh man look at his face
[Applause]
series
[Music]
oh Evo Grand finals
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
oh